ثلاث سفن ونحو الف حلم بالرسوب في بر
الامان طالب اللجوء الالف نجو من الغرق
والموت المحقق بفضل جمعيات حقوقيه لكن افق
مستقبلهم غير واضح وكذلك مصيرهم رغم قصر
المسافه التي تفصلهم عن الجنه المتخيله او
البر الاوروبي اوضحت منظمه اطباء بلا حدود
ان
572 شخصا ما يزالون عالقين على متن
سفينتها جيوبرنس بينما تحمل السفينه اوشن
2349 شخصا ما زالوا عالقين على متن
السفينه 1
واساءه هذا الوضع الكارثي لم تتوقف نداءات
الاستغاثه التي يطلقها هؤلاء النا للعواصم
الاوروبيه لاستقبال المنكوبين
حاله الطقس التي ستزداد سوءا في الساعات
القليله القادمه والامكانيات البسيطه
لسفينتنا فاننا نطالب على الفور بمكان امن
للاشخاص الذين علمتنها هذه ليست امنيه هذا
حق الجميع
حوافز ماليه للدول الاعضاء من اجل استقبال
اللجوء الذين يتم انقاذهم فيما يزداد
الوضع سوءا على متن هذه السفن وفقا
للعاملين في المجال الانساني فهي تحمل
العديد من الاطفال والقاصرين الموجودين
بمفردهم دون عاقل
الجفاف في افريقيا وارتفاع اسعار المواد
الغذائيه
وازدياد البطاله وتفشي الامراض وغيرها من
الاسباب تدفع الكثير من الناس الى ركوب
قوارب الموت والمجازه بارواحهم ومن ينجو
من الغرق تبقى اماله عالقه وسط امواج
البحر